hello everyone and welcome back
so today we have a very interesting
session is coming up and that is known
as call working with react and redux
friend this is one of the most important
topic for those those who are working on
a react and they are thinking about how
the redux can be so important for all of
them
so let's get started and talk about
redux more so first of all
this is the conversation is going on
with say like hey i'm creating a react
application for the shopping cart
feature so the person is saying that
that's great
so but say like
typically if i'm developing a shopping
cart based application so it is
difficult to realize like how i would be
taking care about the state management
of my application because
state management for any application
whether it is a mobile base whether it's
a desktop base it is very very essential
which centralizes store
the state of your application and from
there it distributes to all
they say why don't you use a tool name
called redux which is one of the most
popular tool available in market
okay so now the conversation starts i
can can you tell me like
what exactly the redux is and how i can
get a benefit out of this so let's get
started about this conversation
so what is the redux why we use it the
principles
the advantages and disadvantages and
some short demos
well
here
why redux see the important aspect of
the redux is basically it says the state
is an object any application will
certainly have a state and that state
needs to be stored okay which contains
lot of properties related to many
different aspects of your code okay that
needs to change over the period of time
like you upload any picture in your
facebook the number of likes change
frequently so the state can be modified
based on what the user actions or the
network changes
so every time when the state objects
changes
react application automatically
re-renders the new component states back
to the
client
so a state objects can have a multiple
properties like you can see about if you
upload any
new status in your
i would say uh
facebook so you can say like it contains
comments it contains a number of likes
it contains multiple aspects okay tags
so these are multiple properties of any
application
okay so in a larger play you can see the
large scale application you can have a
several components with so many number
of objects and every time this
application keeps switching keep
changing the state so you need to have
the centralized management of holding
all the states
okay so from your desktop or from mobile
you go to the web and access
your resources
and
frequently
they say this is because the state of
the application while switching was
stored and then re-rendered
when switched it back
okay so the state object needs to be
managed and the redux is just the same
which takes care about what the state
management so redux is nothing but one
of the very very popular
javascript framework which helps to
maintain the state without writing
maximum efforts
of the coding so it is a state
management tool and it can work or
accommodate it not only with react with
any sort of applications
okay so the redux is taking care about
the states and whichever
component needs that state it will be
immediately available to them
so let's to understand what are the
pillars of redux so the principle of
redux number one single source of truth
that means there will be only one store
and which will maintain the complete
object tree where the complete state
will be stored without any hurdle okay
so it is easy to debug and it is faster
development
and single state tree also make it
easier to debug or inspect of your
application and this development time is
anytime faster
now the next thing is we're talking
about the status read-only that means
you can't change it but rather you're
going to get the new state every time
when the new changes comes into your
application
okay so there's no state changes and
actions are nothing but a call of plane
objects
okay
now
here
the next application is all about
changes are made with pure functions a
pure function means a function is so
called pure which doesn't make any rest
api call i'll be clear it is just
responsible to take your inputs and
return you the new output
so it is easy to manage
okay because it is you are you're
talking about mutating the previous
states and because
reducers are just a functions which are
also called pure function it is very
easy for us to maintain such kind of
applications
so
so there are the quick three pillars of
a redux
application okay store
actions
reducers so store when we talk about so
they are the one which takes care about
the complete tree of the state
management okay so
that's where exactly the complete
changes and the chain will be maintained
so get state is a function which is
responsible to return the current state
of your store dispatch is the one which
is responsible to dispatch an action
like any action like in clicking on the
button
or requesting some new things from our
application
subscribe that means you are subscribing
for any change to your application and
unsubscribe means uh you want to be get
updated about any changes which are
happening behind the scene
actions like you can see these are just
a plain object they are the mediator
between the reducers as well as what
your
back end application so they are just
like in plain actions which are
given to your
client the client as a react will be
calling these functions and they will be
in turn
hold the data and pass on further to
where to the reducers now so they are
the payloads of the information and send
the data of your application to your
store
any data you talk about ui network calls
or whatever it is
okay now the reducers
are something which needs to act on
every time when the state applications
changes of your code
okay and it is the one which accepts the
current state and it is the new state
based on what actions you have performed
and the combined users are the one which
are combining multiple reduces together
and act as a common registry when
multiple reducers are joined together
okay now let's talk about some pros and
cons of redux
so process of using redux that means
advantages we are talking about so this
is always one source of truth so there
will be no confusion state is completely
in sync and there's a single resource
where the states are getting maintained
it is a very much predictable outcome
you know it very well what to
give and what to receive
so it is more stated so the code is more
consistent and easy to manage and very
simple optimized and user friendly
mechanism and track every single change
in a real time
okay these are the pros cons which we
talk about no encapsulation so it can
leads to some security issues
boilerplate it happens sometimes when
you need to write this code repeatedly
throughout your application
memory usage so it does uses the memory
okay when the changes are updates and
updates are happening so
it is returning a new state every time
so
it sometime uses the accessor memory
which leads to some more
bloater of the code
so we are now clear about how the redux
works and now it's time to talk about a
demo
okay everyone so it's time to basically
talk about like
how you will be installing a react
applications into your current
environment
look friends if you are interested on
creating a new
react applications
okay so we have a very simple steps to
follow number one if you want to create
a new react applications you can quickly
create
by opening up the node.js terminal
and there you can install this
dependency by saying npm space i space
create hyphen
react hyphen app space hyphen g
so friends what this command does
so you have to go inside your command
prompt and type this command npm space i
space create hyphen react hyphen app
space iphone g
this command will download the necessary
tool called create react app okay from
the web environment and get it installed
into your global location
that is very essential if you want to
start working with the create react app
project
and once this is ready the next step
what you have to follow is to create
another project by saying npm
or sorry
create
create hyphen
react hyphen app
okay and after that you have to use the
tool name called
my
app
so this my app will be the name of the
project
which you need to
create so create react app is a tool
which you have recently downloaded in
your
current environment
using hyphen g and after that you have
to use this create react app and create
a new project with a name called my app
so this will create a boilerplate
project of the
react application and once you say
create react app my app so the next step
what you have to do is you have to use
the cd command
okay by saying my app
so you have to go inside this new
project and you have to use npm space
start
so npm spaces start will be the another
command which will help you to create or
to start or launch your react
application
okay so the step number one is this and
the second step you have to create like
this
okay so that's the way how your new
project is gonna be
creating it for you so
here in my
application if i start my terminal
so i'm here under my
desktop
okay and i can go back and create a new
project here
by because this is i have to do it very
first which is already done i've already
installed this in my machine i can go
back and create the second command call
create
hyphen
react hyphen app space
my app the moment i hit enter it is
going to create a new project for me
and it'll take a while
and it'll ask it is asking me like you
do not have a permission
so let me go back and create a
permission to my application
now
it is
getting it ready
so initially it will take some time
to get your dependencies downloaded and
create a fresh folder structure into
your desktop but in case if you are a
window user i would recommend that you
use
your c drive or d drive wherever you are
comfortable and there you perform all
the actions here you can see the my app
folder is created and here all the
necessary dependencies are getting ready
and it is downloading all the necessary
steps for me
okay
so let's come back once it is ready
okay everyone so you can see here i've
got this my project ready with me
and
once it is ready it is asking me about a
few things it is telling me like
if you want to start working with this
project you have to use cd space my app
as i said earlier
this is the command which you have to
use city space my app so i'm saying city
space my app
and i'm saying npm space start
something npm space starts it will
launch my
application and the server will pick up
so let's see if i have any applications
running under the same port
so
once again let me rewrite or rerun it
again
so it is launching my application now
okay it is having some permission issues
due to that it is coming up so i can
just use
the sudo command before
and
[Music]
now it will pick up my application
now you can see my application is
initiated
great so guys this is where exactly you
get your react application ready
and yes
in case if you want to
[Music]
develop a redux based application so you
have to download some additional
dependencies too so you have to say
npm space i
space
redux
space
react hyphen
redux
so these two dependencies you really
require in case if you want some
additional set of
redux facility you want so i'm just
saying sudo
and now
it is downloading all the necessary
dependencies for my code
there we go so friends that is the way
how you perform
the necessary
setup for the react and redux
application
and after that we will start working
with a sample application and react of
redux
okay everyone so since
our application is all set
okay so we are all good okay to take our
development to the next level so here we
would like to show you how you can
develop
something very basic react and redux
application which can help you to get a
basic setup ready of counter example
okay so how to start working with react
and redux so before i proceed ahead this
is the folder structure for me
okay and
in this folder structure i'm going to
create another this is actually the one
which i've imported in my vs code editor
and here i would like to create a new
folder here under my src
saying
or i can see the redux demo
and under this redirects demo i can
create a new file here called
counter.js
and inside this contact.js i would like
to import some dependencies by saying
import
react from
react
and
let's go and create a new class by
saying export
default
class
counter
extends
component
now this is the way how you always
create a class
okay inside your react which have a one
render function
which returns a jsx code to you
i have a call return
and here it returns a jsx code to me i'm
just writing a very simple message
called div
and saying
welcome
to
react
app
so this is my a very simple counter
example
which extends component
this counter i would like to use it in
my index.js file
and inside this i say
counter
and the moment i say counter added in my
index.js i will say npm space
start
to get my
project
ready
okay
it is saying it is running so you want
to run
hit enter
let us pick up its own
port number
so 3.0001 and i'm getting this message
called welcome to react app
very simple so i have got this
counter example
which component
i have delivered to my browser and it's
time to develop some
kind of a counter application and for
this
what i will do is
here
i want to bring
some
buttons so i say
button
and i'm saying
increment
i have another button
called
decrement so we have two buttons with me
increment and decrement
okay and these buttons
will call some functions which i'm
writing it here i'm saying inc
okay and i'm also using
dec
that means increment and decrement and
here i just write alert
by saying
called just for to confirm
whether these are getting called or not
so i'm saying
called
and here we'll be attaching those even
by saying on click
equal to
inc
and here we are saying once again
equal to
okay and we will check if it are working
fine
so
perfect it is getting called
it is getting called yes so alert was
just an idea
to check whether the functions are
getting invoked properly or not
okay
now
the first step in case if you want to
perform
this
type of development remember one thing
you always starts with
creating a reducer so to create a
reducer what i will be doing it i'm
going to create a new file here
called
intext.js
okay
so i'm creating a very simple file
called index.js and here i will try to
apply but fortunately i already have
index.js file with me
okay in my
this location so here itself i can
create some initializing the state
so in my application
uh
i'm already having this counter with me
so let me go back and download some
dependencies first
so the first thing what i need to import
is called counter which is anyways we
have taken it up
next
i would like to import
from
react hyphen networks
okay i'm just keeping those dependencies
blank which later on i will tell you
what those meanings are
i'm using
import from
products some of the dependencies are
there
okay so the step number one what you
will be doing you will be initializing
the state so here in my application
okay i would like to initialize my state
by saying
const
state okay equal to
let me initialize my state
okay i will say with the value call
count
colon zero
okay and furthermore we will go ahead
step by step
well
this is what our state was called
initial state count column what
a zero
okay so what i would like to do here is
i would like to create
some
functionality here
okay which is nothing but a call reducer
function like i told you earlier it is a
kind of pure function which will be
helping you to return the state back to
your application
okay so i'm first of all saying function
reducer
okay it takes two parameter
state
equal to
initial state
comma
action okay and here we are using switch
in this switch we are confirming what
type of action client will invoke if i
say action dot
type
okay now we will check which type of
action client may invoke if my action
is type of what
increment
if the action is type of
increment
then
it returns
count
colon
state dot
count plus 1 it will increment the
counter by 1.
okay that's the one thing
and second thing i will try to copy this
if the case is of what type
decrement so here
it will say
-1
okay otherwise i'll return
otherwise i will return the default
state i am saying
return
state
that's the condition is
okay after this what i will be doing is
i have to create a store because see
them ideas like store i told you earlier
in my ppt it is the one which contain
the single source of truth okay so you
need to create it so after this i'll
create
const
store equal to
create
store
see it comes from redux
okay from where you have to create a
store so say create store and here you
password
reducer
okay so this reducer is nothing but
the one
which you have recently created on the
top
okay so your store will collect the
state by having the multiple reducers
utilized here
and now once it is ready
so i'll be using one tool name called
provider guys provider is basically
called as a bridge which is responsible
to collect the state
okay from the different store and from
there it make it available to the
consumer which is so called components
so provider works as a bridge
from collecting the state from multiple
locations so far from store and make it
available to the components so provider
is the tool comes from the react hyphen
redux
okay
oh so what we need to do here in my
application
i would like to use
provider
so you can see it is a provider
inside this provider i will wrap
my counter and this provider will take
the
store
from where
from the store store is what the one
which is creating this tool and through
this store it is making this estate
available to home to my counter
okay so the counter will get what the
initialize
state with the default value called what
a 0 and that we can make it available to
my
application
so i hope you are clear about
how the state is going to be
you know utilized by the components so
in my counter.js if i want to get my
state visible to my application here i
have to basically go and create one more
function here
okay that is called function
map
to
crops
and this map state to props function
will be holding
the status and parameter and here it
says return
it says return and here i'm saying count
is a local variable i'm declaring it
colon
state dot
count so count is the variable which you
remember we have
made it a variable
okay with my initializing the state and
this count variable will be available to
wear to my application and this
map state to props since it is written
outside of this component i have to
create one more
function called default connect so this
is the connect function which is
responsible to connect this map state to
plot function which is getting the state
from the reducer to your current
component so in this connect i will pass
a first parameter called map state to
props and the component name which is
responsible to consume your state
okay
because it is export default connect we
are already doing it so we will be
removing it from here because in a
single file one component can have
default
okay and we can make
this counter visible
in my current application
clear so this counter you can display
okay by using this dot props dot count
so here
in your render
wherever you are using this now okay you
can display the counter here
so you can see
count colon
this dot
props dot
count
so that's how
your
application is basically designed
okay so it's having some issues which
will be fixing it
okay but here that's the first thing
which your counter example is being
taken it up
okay everybody so you see like here my
code is almost ready everything is there
let me check by my browser
and you can see here
it is working perfectly fine
okay and here in your application you
see
we have got count
and the initial value call 0 the one
which you initialize from index.js
it is visible to me
that's perfect
okay now i would like to
invoke an actions
and these actions will be further
incrementing or decrementing that means
these actions will be calling those
reducer functions
and these reducer functions
will be calling through what
so this
our
counter so we have a counter here
and these counters i'll be calling it
and to check how they're getting called
internally so index.js
is the one which will be helping us to
invoke all those one by one so let's see
how we can call those from my counter
so in step number one in case if i want
to call those
in my increment okay so i just use this
error sign
and here in my inc
i just use this option like in this dot
props dot
dispatch
this is the predefined function dispatch
in which
we have to tell which type of action we
are trying to invoke so we are saying
type
colon what
and this is the name which should match
with this action the one which you
created increment
okay so your action will get called and
the value will get increment let's check
awesome you can see now it is invoking
this action and this action is basically
internally helping me to
invoke the number of count and the same
thing i will try to perform
for my decrement also let me call this
here
and make it as an error function
and say decrement
and let's see
perfect so it is working fine so friends
that is a complete example of like how
in your react you'll be responsible
for
invoking these dispatchers which are
nothing but a call a typical
way of invoking your
reducers behind the scene and these
reducers
will be performing your necessary
actions after accepting the data
from the input so now you can see we
have a call incremented agreement
it is a pure function it is taking your
actions and returning you what the new
state of your applications
so that's where your simple example is
so this particular example we have
created for you
to offer you something
very comprehensive in a reactors
react.js what happens like
we know at our previous demonstrations
we have used a lot about
redux for the state management tool we
have told you like redux is
a very well known state management tool
and redux comes with
host of
new features like
you talk about action you talk about
reducer
you talk about provider
so multiple things are there
now the important thing is
when being a client of any react-based
application if i have to use
react
redux features so we have to use a
correct
so in our previous demonstrations you
have seen we were using map state to
props for retriving retrieving the state
from the redux and we were using
map dispatch to props for dispatching an
action
and these two functions map state to
props and map dispatch to props
okay
we have to associate with connect
function
which is a part of react hyphen redux
many of you
initially might have felt
this looks quite complicated
yeah
so
react has offered you
the
very simplest way to communicate with
your backend state management tool which
is so called redux
in very very simplified manner
now in the latest version
you neither require any connect function
on the client
nor you require map state to props or
map dispatch to props
rather you have got some new functions
are available which i'm going to show to
you right now here
so here in my src if i see
this one container folder under this we
have called product listing
this is a very simple example of like
how
you can load the list of
products from the backend apis
so
we are using
once again axios to load the list of
dummy products from my backend
but the intention is like how we can
maintain the state
so
here we have used two very interesting
features
one is called use dispatch and second is
called use selector
and they come from react iphone redux
what is the benefit of this
the benefit of using used dispatch and
use selector is
they are the absolutely alternative too
they are absolutely alternative to map
state to props
and this is an alternative to map
dispatch to props and you do not need
any more connect function
so u selector is designed to get the
state
from your packet
okay so if you can see here
this example we are having one property
called dispatch
where we are associating this u's
dispatch
okay
and
to dispatch
the data what we have retrieved from my
back end
which we are anyways using the x use
and from this axios
after making the call
whatever the data i'm getting it i'll be
setting this data
to my back end so i'm dispatching this
so if you see
dispatch
is a property which is associated with
this use dispatch
and using this dispatch
okay you are directly calling the action
set products is nothing but a call
your action
okay and under this you're passing
response to data so if i open up
here in my action
okay so you can see we were called set
products
okay so here i'm calling set products
and under this we are sending
the data which you are retrieving it
from our backend
so it's a very simple way
okay so this dispatch is directly
calling this
your action function and passing the
data whatever retry from the client
so that is for dispatching
for retrieving the current state
what you're doing you will be using
this statement like
use
selected
okay so the use selector is the another
feature okay through which you will be
retrieving the state so now you can see
i'm saying you selected and i'm getting
the state and i'm saying state dot all
products dot products
so what is the all product is nothing
but my
combined user property
so if i see my combined reducer
so using this state which is a just a
keyword i'm calling this all products
which is my combined user property
so if i if i see my reducers
index.js you can see this one property
called all products
in my combined users so this all product
i'm basically calling this
and accessing its property called
products
so now you just understand this u
selector is completely replacing
the necessity of
your
map state to props
and this
next function called dispatch which is
called use dispatch is completely
replacing
the necessity of map dispatch to props
and you do not need connect function
so these are the new features
which helps the developer to make their
development little more easier
okay so i'm sure you got the clarity of
how this is really used
okay everyone so we have recently seen
how this use selector
and
use dispatch
is replacing the traditional technique
now
there is another very interesting
feature which is available
we all know that redux is designed for
state management
and is a pure client side management
state management tool
but the big question still is the same
where the state is getting stored in
tomorrow if i want to know
i want to see those states in my
application
if i want to know where the state was
saved
what was my previous states which
actions are called
so to debug this complete situation
redux is offering you very comprehensive
tool
that is called redux dev tools
redux dev tools is
a very very important aspect for the
redux developers
here if i see my package.json
okay
so
initially you do not need
any specific tool
for
state management
sorry so called your redux step tools it
comes by default
but how to configure this
so to configure this
this redux dev tools
here in your store.js
you have to define this statement
called window.redux type tool extension
underscore
underscore underscore
and and windows dot redux step tool
extension
this line you have to write it for sure
in order to identify
the
previous state and what actions you have
called
this is very important without this
your
redux state management which is
happening
you can't debug it so you're allowing by
telling okay i want my current
applications to have
the dev tools available
okay
so once this is ready with me how will i
use this
so to use this what we need to do is
because
the dev tool is
absolutely a browser-based tool so if i
just open up here
okay and if i say
redux
so you will see the first option you
will get redux dev tools
it is a tool
offered by the redux dev tools
and
you have to install it since in my
browser it is already installed
but in your
you have to install it first
okay
so once you install
what you need to do is
here
let me try to launch this first
let my application start
and the moment it starts it'll load
some default data from the back end
you can see now
some backend data
some dummy data is now loaded
and here
you see there's an option called redux
drive tools
it enabled because it is installed
and here
i have this option
in a panel
okay you can see this is the
how the redux devtools really looks like
in
it is the
[Music]
i would say
a
a kind of plugin which will hold all the
records now you can see it is by default
calling
the set products which is an action for
me
and if i select any product
you can see now there's another action
get called
and these are all what the properties of
this particular action
if i click on back it'll call remove
selected products
and once again if i select any of this
product once again it is loading the
other products
i go back
and load another one
so many products are there which i can
you use it now
now i can see so these are all multiple
actions
it is internally invoking to tell which
are the actions are there
and what is happening is if you see
if i select this drop down if i say
chart
you you'll be quite surprised to see how
beautifully
this example
is offering you
the charting
you see this now
this is the products are there this is
the state has been maintained behind the
scene
okay and it locks the complete state so
if i press the play button
you will get to know what happened
see now earlier it loaded all the
products now it is once again loading
unloading
now you can see
the complete state
is maintained behind the scene and it's
storing
the previous state
what it was when the user was selected
and now you understand
what this redux type tool is
it is a beautiful tool
designed for
giving you
the better
productivity
in terms of debugging your application
knowing what is going on
okay so make sure
two things you need to do
number one
you have to enable this
and pause that
you have to have a redux dev tool
installed
then only you can have this
thank you
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simply learn youtube channel and
click here to watch similar videos to
nerd up and get certified click here